welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled tips for successful
single cell and single nuclear
nucleus rna-seq it's my pleasure to
introduce you to luciano martillato
scientific director single cell core
laboratory
at harvard medical school for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen if any questions arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me in welcoming
luciano martellato i will now turn the
presentation over to him
uh hello everyone hey for those who
don't know me uh you know my name is
jenna i work at a harvard medical school
at the
singleside core laboratory and it's my
pleasure today to
you know give you a full list of tips
for single cell
experiments uh this is our my
what i like to call my notes from the
lab um
you know just as a full disclosure these
are my understanding of what i
of of the single self feel the things
that i've collected over the years
that i've been doing this and i just put
them on a series of slides
and i would like to share those with you
especially mostly for those
that are just starting in the single
cell field i think this is going to be
quite useful so the chalk is divided
into
two sessions the the part a
is i'm going to try to cover a a series
of topics here
that are blacked out and and hopefully
i can cover that within 15 minutes 50
minutes or so and then we're gonna stop
and then we move to the next
session in in which is after after this
session finishes in in about an hour
okay so but uh essentially these are the
all the topics that i would like to
cover today uh if if we if you manage to
have time
i will leave a few minutes at the end to
to have a few questions
so one of the things that i uh you know
the reason why i started doing
biology or sinusoidal genomics is when i
actually realized that we have so many
cells in our body you know there are
nearly 40 trillion cells in our body
which
you know and and after the
the the application of single cells we
were able to identify you know roughly
around 200 cells and i think is
the more single cell experiment we do
and the more atlases we start building
the more we realize that we have
actually more cell types
and in the past most of these studies
have been done
when we've been doing genomics or
transcriptomics most of these have been
done
using a bulk analysis that is
taking the rna or the dna from millions
of hundreds of millions of cells
at once so and obviously when you do
that
it's a very informative approach and you
know it help us understand
a lot of of the genomics and tracking
atomics of
of the of of the of the of the human and
and also from from animal models but
what we are getting from that is an
average signal so essentially what
you're getting is
is a signal that contains everything
that is in there
usually is the model population or the
population is more abundant
and but what we wanted to do is actually
understand what is the actual
granularity of the data
how many cells do we have there are all
the cells the same are different
and the reason why we were not doing
that it was because it was a technical
uh problem here so and the problem was
that we don't have
sufficient material in a single cell to
actually do
the or to apply it in the past the
method that we were doing to
to actually detect you know a mutation
or detect
a transcript uh or differences in in
transcription
so and and this is in the last
13 years i would say there's been an
enormous progress in
in the understanding of uh of how to
actually tackle the
chinese heart and that's when the
singular genomic field
started to build up
sorry i'm trying to okay so as i
mentioned before we have nearly
40 trillion cells and every single cell
has around 6.6 billion dna bases
and this is already this is in every
single cell and if you can see that
all the epigenetic modifications that
become makes
the complexity of everything every cell
even bigger
so at any given time this is just
roughly
you may have around 50 000 molecules of
rna
and only nearly less than one percent is
in the nucleus and the majority of the
rna
is in the in the cytosol and
you know in this case it's just taking
this case is taking into account
all this not all this press g no the
genes are expressed at the same time
and you have a lot of uh transcription
of variants and in this
case are splice variants for example
and that all of those transcripts are
translated into thousands of proteins
and if you consider the our
immune cells for example they have you
their unique repertoire of antibodies
which make things
the complexity of a particular tissue
extremely extremely high that's why we
what we want to do is just to move from
the other resolution that we have in the
past in which we had a tissue and we
were able to
dissect the tissue and observe under the
microscope and then from there we moved
to something in which we actually get an
average signal
so we take a sample we do the rna
sequence or
or dnac and we get an average signal
from that
and we want to move from something like
that to something in which we actually
can resolve
all the cells that this particular
tissue and all the different
components and all the different cell
types that actually compo
forming that particular tissue so in a
way what we want to do for example if
you have a disease like
like a tumor case uh like a tumor in
this case
you don't only have two more cells so
what you have is an ecosystem
and that ecosystem will consist in in
tumor cells and in normal cells
and uh what are all the stroma cells and
you have
immune infiltrate that are trying to
target
the tumor just to get rid of it and you
also you have endothelial cells and all
of that that are try to
to kind of feed the tumor or that's the
the system that the tumor hijacked to
actually survive
so what we want to do is to be able to
resolve those cell populations and then
use a computational analysis to be
to resolve potential differential
expression between the cell and see what
things are different between the tumor
and the normal cells
now obviously when we look at the tumor
you probably have seen this
like many times before uh but what i
liked about this slide is because for
the non-expert in the heterogeneity
or on single cell it it sort of put a
picture of
how we can interpret the different how
the different technologies have been
adding to this disentangling of the
complexity of a particular tissue so
imagine a tissue
a complex tissue as a as a bowl of
fruits
right so you can but then you can apply
different technologies and
and get different resolutions so for
example when we were doing bulk genomics
which would
which is what i was mentioning before we
will be able to
er to come we can compare that as a
preparedness smoothie so you can
see get a zip of that smoothie and say
okay well i think
here maybe we have strawberry when we
have some pineapple
and maybe have some banana but you don't
know exactly in what
proportion you actually have those
things in there right
but then if you combine that with other
powerful techniques like a flow
cytometry
or or and you can which means you can
actually separate
all the different components of the the
individual
components into different categories and
all the different fruit and prepare
different smoothings and then you can
say okay well you know i have
all of these these are this is pineapple
smoothie this is a
strawberry smoothie hey whatever so and
but you know that's a good but again we
we know that within the especially
within the particular tissue not all the
cells that
are composing no all the epithelial
cells are the same
so when we combine that with single cell
genomics and and
flow cytometry we are able to understand
how much differences or what the
differences are within a particular um
type right and that's what this is
trying to sort of emphasize
now what is it more exciting is that now
we are moving to
you know from single cell space which we
actually take a tissue we dissociate
in in all the single cells and then
we analyze that in the in into into
single
genomics or single cell transcriptomics
but we lose
an important component of that which is
the
physical location of that particular
cell and that is something that we're
not going to
talk today but this is this is the field
of a spatial tranquitomics
which allows you to essentially see the
position not just only the component the
particular cell or the particular
components of the tissue but it also
tells you exactly
where that component was located and
what's the proximity with other cells
and how they may be
interacting and you can sort of see all
the predictions that you get from single
cell genomics to see whether that pans
out
in the actual location okay so this is
as i say this is a very
uh introductory uh
sort of a few slides just to understand
how complex
humans and and oh sorry how
complications in general not just only
humans
are are and and what is that we what we
are trying to do
uh single cell genomics and how we why
we are evolving to
a single cell uh or special tranquility
now one of the main reasons why we do
single cell genomics is because you know
the biology of the systems are really
complex we have a lot of
tissue heterogeneity here is an example
of a
series of disney plots in would you
every single part single dot will
represent a particular cell and all the
colors represent a cell type
so what you can see that you can see
some cell types that are represented in
every single one of the tissue but the
composition
and the enumeration of that may be
different and some
the cell types are particular for a
particular tissue
or specific for a particular tissue so
the
the tissues and the uh and the tissues
and and and the organs
are very very complex and we cannot
really uh
uh getting uh assumed that all the sec
the single the second position of all
the jesus is
is the same so that's why this is
something that obviously become
more obvious when we started doing uh
the atlases of all these tissues
now the there is a lot of cellular
heterogeneity so for example if you take
the cell cycle
all right so you say the cells are not
all you know they are not all the cells
if you take a tissue and you dissociate
the cells into
individual cells not all the cells are
in the same
state right so they some cells are
dividing some cells are
arrested some things are differentiated
so the cells are
actually continuously moving in this
internal clock that is the cell cycle so
there is a heterogeneity in there
now in a tissue there are cells that are
dimes
and there are live answers that are
already dead all right so this is also
some
a very important aspect of heterogeneity
within the cell
there is a regulatory network so all the
cells interact with each other it's not
that every single cell is a single
entity this is a tissue this is a system
every single system has a
are working towards an ultimate goal
which is survival
then we have gene relationships right so
the gene the expression of one gene
tells the expression of another gene a
mutation in one particular gene
is only going to be effective if there
is a mutation in another gene okay
and and you get all these epistemic
interactions between
genes so that's happen and and can
happen within within tissues and
especially within disease
and that it's it's something that you
can only see
at the level of the single cells and you
have clonotypes for example you can
you know in the case of um immune
immune cells you have you know different
clonotypes and and that that is based on
the vdj recombination
of the the tcr for example in this case
that i'm showing here and and that
generates a lot of it originating in
terms so you may be all of that those
are t cells but
they are different clones they they are
supposed to target different
uh part of the androgen or different
antigens and may
some of them are not yet targeting
anything right
and then also if you look at the cells
in a differentiation path they may be
actually a located along a
differentiation path
and it's a that is also a la
gives a little bit of an extra
complexity
of heterogeneity to the system so as you
can see depending on how you see this
system you can actually you it can get
very very very complex so and now if you
look at the
at the organism level you know you can
see that
this is a true example examine a frog an
example of zebrafish
in which for example you can take
different um
samples you take the different
the the embryo at the different stages
and then you do adolescence of all the
says
involving that and you can see how there
is a lot of
you can actually track the evolution of
that particular
uh embryo from the it's a very mature to
actually to mature
and you can see that there is a lot of
complexity in how
this individual how the entire organism
changes and we don't we do these little
plots not because they are beautiful but
because we want to know exactly why
a cell decide to take one path or the
other and this is something that
has been a you know one of these most
important development in the last
couple of years which is this organism
organismal development the ability to
use super powerful
computational programs to understand how
a
from a stem cell we can actually derive
so many different cell types and
actually
create an entire organism
so obviously none of this would have
been
possible if we didn't have an explosion
in the
uh saw and the technology and also
in the in the throughput that we can get
from technology so
we started in in mid 2009 when just only
the ability to do a one single seller on
asic
to now with the you know with the
being able to do millions of cells at
once and
you know obviously this has been an
evolution of all these technologies
every single technology has uh
contributed to
the evolution of another technology this
is when the technique
sort of technology brings more
technology and then
we have all seen an explosion in the
amount of cells that we can actually
profile at a given time when we
observe when the microfluidic devices
come up
with something like dropsic in drop or
10x genomics that we're able to
to sort of uh bring the number of cells
that we can profile at once
to in the number of thousands of tens of
thousands
and in the last couple of years what he
what i've been you know what up for me
is
that you know i'm a person that loves
technology and i like to see all these
new papers and new technologies that
comes around you can see
that it's been in a tremendous amount of
new technologies there is every single
something something something
sick and you can see that all of those
are some of them
are actually very small changes from
previous technologies
but some of them are extremely cool one
of the
you know you have cases like it have
changed the way that we actually do
single cell profiling like for example
sightseeing
okay and and then you have all the
situations in which you are able to
perturb
to do crispr screens you just modify
some different changes and that
it's has a have allowed us to see to see
the the system uh or any
any profile in a different way so for
example now we have
we are generating thousands of of
hundreds of
um of atlases from different tissues
from different
cell types from different type of
disease so now we are going we're moving
to some
to now we need to perturb those systems
and now we are going to enter in another
staging which actually have atlases of
perturb systems
so and all of these techniques here they
have contributed to that
to for they are contributing to that to
be something real okay
and and i just want to highlight that
this is this is just
you know a few of the tech that has been
coming up in the last year or two and
but the least
continuous and this this is it's amazing
to see
and it's very exciting to to live in
this time in which you see all of these
things coming up
i would love to go over all of these but
unfortunately we don't have time but
this is this is an amazing
incredible amount of tech and if you
have time to have a look at those
i would i strongly recommend so
now in terms of application for single
cell aeronastic okay so there is a there
is an obvious
underlying reason why we all do this is
because we want to
uh you know explore the
exploit the ability to examine the any
transcription
transcription variation that makes it
between individual cells
so it doesn't matter whether you are
trying to identify or characterize a
cell population or you wanted to
determine how heterogeneous the
populations are or to
uncover new cell types and you know get
some evidence of potential rare cell
types
or whether you want to understand how
the
population changes over time what do you
want to see
whether that is a sort of some
you want to understand the lineage and
differentiation programs of a particular
organism or you want to see whether
there is any new
what's the nuances of all these
interactions within the
cellular pathways understand gene
regulation something that we know
we we had inside the general regulation
in the past we were thinking okay well
you know genes express and
turn on and off but then we've seen in
the last a
few years there'll be a few papers in
and that's stochastic
activation of of genes or you know
seeing that not every cell actually
expresses genes at the same time which
is
you know this is this is a fantastic
discovery and
at least to me some it showed how little
we knew before
and you know you may want to
characterize the new profile or you want
to know how the tumors respond to
therapy doesn't matter what you do
this is all of this some of your
projects will actually fall
within this this sort of basic um
or sort of high level uh reasons why you
would
may want to do things and of course you
have the ad lasting which is
been a tremendous you know i have had
tremendous success
but as mentioned before this is
something that
now once we got to that point what we
need to do is
start perturbing those atlases and see
what new things come up
so now the point of this talk is not
just to talk about all the things that
we already know
we we already know how complex the
system is that's what you do in single
cell
uh but it just wanted to highlight that
is is
the system can be more complex than we
actually
know what we think it is so now when we
do single cell around sick
there is always a challenge and the
challenge is that even though this is a
technique that have been
or a collection of the techniques that i
have been
doing for being around for you know 11
13 years it's still a new
method right so and because it's new it
suffers from all the things that are new
and also it's changing over time
so something that you thought oh this is
an amazing technique now
to in a month or two you may not be as
good
okay so you will see that there was a
lot of papers around with super cool
techniques
that would never be used okay and
so and that's it's because some of them
are extremely challenging and
challenging to to implement
so some of the things that are very
challenging is
uh you know they have to do with two
parts one is the web lab
and the oldest is the dry lab the dry
lab will be all the informatics that are
behind
you know just that allow us the well of
people like myself
to actually look at an issue from a
different perspective
it's like you know imagine you you have
a tissue that is
like a lego and then you know that you
have the lego you have different pieces
but if you you can tease them apart
but they these dry love people these
buying for magicians alas i like to call
them
they allow us to see that every single
piece can actually be observed in
different ways and we can connect all
these pieces in different way and that
is
it's amazing okay but
there are challenges there and there is
there is a beautiful paper
that is called the level grand
challenges of single cell data science
which is not taking not only taking into
account current
problems but you take into account also
problems that may come
and and and and i strongly recommend you
to
to to have a look at those and and and
again
this is this is just the the
only 11 but i'm sure they will become
that there will be more coming in the
future when we collect more and more
data
now what we are going to talk today is
essentially all the issues
and potential challenges that you are
going to be facing when you want to do
single cell
rna sequencing a nuclear or neck or even
if you do single cell a tactic
or any multi-modal analysis in the lab
in the web lab
and the things that you need to consider
from sample prep
to sequencing okay
so it doesn't matter what type of
experiment
you're going to do every single cell
around a single
cell a single nuclear attack a rna
sequencing
attacks echo a combination of both there
are four
major uh steps that you you're gonna be
you're you're gonna have to go through
so the first one is the sample process
and cell isolation
you're gonna see them all in a little
bit of detail the second
one is the cell bar coding and
sequencing which is essentially
separation of the of the cell individual
cells then you are going to sequence
that and then you have to process
okay so you you need to do all the
mapping the the
generating the account matrix and things
like that
but then after that you need to do the
data analysis which is mostly the
interpretation okay
and we're not gonna focus in the
three and four but we're gonna pay a lot
of attention in the first two
okay now
the goal of the single cell anesthetic
experiment of the goal when you try to
process your sample is one which is
to prepare a live single cell suspension
and some people you know i the reason is
again this is this is just my opinion
this is
this by no means is is a brown truth
but this is something that i've seen for
a while people
prepare the samples and sometimes uh
they forget very basic stuff okay like
for example
uh you and these are the high level
considerations that i want you to bring
to your attention and things that you
need to consider before
you actually go into the lab okay and
start processing this tissue
so one is that you need to consider the
species that you are working with it's
not the same
if you work with mouse or if you work
with humans if you work with zebra fish
because the way that you would process
these tissues is
different and the way to preserve the
viability which is the
one of the main important part of this
of this sample processing
is different we have cases in which we
had a
fish for example that was from from from
high soil content
waters and the cells will not survive
the dissociation okay the cells will die
and they will die until we figured out
why we
we we had many failed attempts and one
thing that we were not considering is
the species this species is an
inspiration that lives in high
water content so we have soil content
water so what we needed to do is just to
maintain the high soil content until the
very last moment
which was the encapsulation of that so
in this particular case we even have to
modify
the chip to be able to to work with this
but this is something that is important
to consider because if you forget about
that you may have a lot of failed
experiments
okay now the other thing that you need
to consider is a solid if it is a solid
tissue
what organ are you working with brain
with breasts
with liver with lung all of these
tissues are different they are different
in terms of the
cellular metrics mainly and they're also
different in the way that you will
target them some of them are more
sensitive some cells and
some tissues obviously have different
composition and
you need to consider that there is a
plenty of protocols available
for different organs and it's
it's important that you don't just go
blindly and
and try to dissociate the tissue with
the oh yeah you know collagenous that's
that works
okay so because it's exactly no it's is
this a situation one of the things that
we need to consider is
what are the composition of that tissue
in terms of translations i will mention
that a little bit in in the top
now if you're working with a liquid
biopsy for example blood that's okay you
know this is
this is a different uh sort of you don't
have to dissociate the tissue but
there is a lot of things that you need
to consider from uh
when when you process this material so
from the blood
draw to the the way to this to the time
that it gets on the lab there was
recently a few papers there was one from
the group of holder hain and there was
another one
a a couple days ago maybe a week ago
about
how sensitive are is a transcription to
all this
time that goes from the sample
processing to the
the sample draw to the lab so that is
part of the sample process
this is not a this is not separated from
the sample processing okay
so we need to consider that when we
actually
prepare in our workflow now the biopsy
size of volume
here it's important that you consider
here the volume on the sides
has nothing to do with the actual size
it has to do with the cellularity of the
tissue
you may have a large volume but it may
be fatty maybe fibrous
and what you want you know how many
cells you have in there okay so
in terms of biopsy side i get a lot of
questions
uh for example what's what's the best
size to do
this a nice well it doesn't matter the
size really
it just no matter how many sets you have
in that little piece okay
so it's important that you know that of
your tissue
uh one thing that you will see if you're
working with pancreas tissue you
sometimes
you have a lot of fat all right if you
work with breasts you have a lot of fat
as well
so you can consider that the same as
when you work with brain which is
pure cells right now
the cell composition is also another
factor to take into account
and that is something that i keep
insisting
for people to know what the second
position of the tissue is i understand
that we're doing this
for atlasine but there is a lot of
already
there is a lot of work already on this
and and
you you need sometimes you can you can
do is it's a
prior it's a pile of experiments in
in would you have determined the cell
population using an orthogonal method
you can use
facts you can do side of you can do
anything you want to
identify what's the same composition the
reason why you do that is because
you may be biased in your sample
processing and maybe you're losing some
of your cells and if you don't do that
what you are doing
is just biasing your single cell around
sick experiment so it's important that
you know what the composition of your
tissues
is if you can all right as much as you
can
now the that's it's also related with
the cellular heterogeneity
not all the cells in the tissue are
going to have
or are going to be in the same
transcriptional state right or
are going to have the same amount of
transcripts in in
rna in the cell so some of them will
have less rna some of this will have
more rna
and when you do the analysis if you're
only focusing those cells a
high level of rna expressions i'm you
know you you may lose that you
they when we first started doing single
nuclear or async
one of the things that we noticed is
that we were losing a lot of the
lymphocytes and
of course this is single nuclear
arrhythmic a is a particular
type of experiment which you normally
have less aromasic less rene
i will show you in a few slides later
but
because we we not considered the
lymphocyte we actually have less rna
and we will actually filter them out so
this is something that you all
you don't sort of take that into account
during the processing but it's important
that you know
what the composition is that's what the
composition is is is important here
now extracellular material composition
it's is of absolute importance because
it's what is going to the timing what
type of digestions you're going to use
okay the extracellular matrix of a tumor
may not be the same from a normal
tissue even from the same organ okay so
and and the strategy from the brain is
not the same from the lung
so you may use the most common enzymes
you know collagen and helium is to do
these
these associations but it's important
that you know that sometimes
if you do that you may be biased biasing
the dissociation the the composition of
your single cell suspension because
you may not be dissociating the cells of
a particular
group because the traceabilian matrix
was different there or require a little
bit longer incubation time
so what you're doing is essentially
removing the cells some of your cells
as a debris because they don't
dissociate well so
it's important that you check that and
and
because it can actually change the way
that you do the association
again there is a lot of protocols around
there in which you actually
can have a look and check now
if you are working with a postmortem
tissue obviously you need to consider
that because
uh these post-modern tissue usually
are in the presence of decay so the
cells are dying
and you're gonna have a lot of cell
death so the the way that you would
process that sample is not going to be
the
same if it's a freshly lab you probably
have to go through
some sort of cell that removal i'm going
to discuss that a little
a little bit again as well because i'm
not really
keen on the cell remover and i will
explain the reasons why later
but you may decide that may decide what
type of
process you're going to do maybe you
want to avoid further death and you may
want to go to seeing a nuclear
organisation okay
we're going to discuss that again a
little bit later now
if you're working with a naive or or
chemotherapy treated tumor
that it's for example is another
situation in which you may decide to
process in one way or another because
you know uh
the chemotherapy through the tumor if
the therapy is a
cytotoxic you may have a lot of cell
death and that's gonna completely ruin
your experiment because what we really
wanted to know
remember is to have a cell that is a
suspension is highly viable
okay and and also you may consider
the way that you process your tissue has
to do with the how you preserve the
tissue okay it's not the same if you
preserve the tissue
using uh some
if you describe your preservation or if
you snap froze the tissue
so if you carry preservation you you
know you can dissociate the tissues in
the normal way
you can just you know do like a few
washes and then you
proceed through the dissociation after
you choose the right enzymes
and and and um procedure but if you do
it's not freezing
you're not going to uh it's not freezing
as in flash pressing just put the tissue
in liquid nitrogen that is not going
to you're not going to have any live
cells there you're probably going to
have junk
so and that's going to change the way
that you process the tissue and
it's likely you're going to have to go
to synchronous it
so now in terms of dissociation and
and and the way that you will actually
decide how to proceed
there are these three beautiful papers
that i
i absolutely recommend to to go and have
a look
these are probably my favorite in in
this
sort of area uh there is one this from
from the group of samuel le parisio and
sorabsha
so this is from flanagan see this is a
very nice paper we are going to discuss
a few of these results here
in which they sort of introduce they
call
they call active process to do
dissociation instead of
collagenase digestion at 37 degrees
and and there's also used here in in the
elena di senko and this is
this is a a colleague of mine in
australia uh
at least a forest so they have that on a
again a beautiful paper these two are
complement
a compliment to each other they they
look at the problem in different angles
some
some things are very similar they found
very similar results
but they both conclude the same
situation called active projects is a
is a very good alternative to um
actually much better alternative than
collagenous uh digestion
and then we have this uh the the one
that i mentioned before from from ramon
badossa so this is
this is from the group of how to hang
this actually they take into account
the processing of a blood
so and how you need you can all the
things that you need to consider from
the moment that you take the sample
draw to the moment that you process and
how the transcriptome and the epigenome
may be
maybe change so if you if you have time
and
if you don't have time just make the
time have a look at this because these
are absolutely amazing papers to
to have uh to have in your mind
now and the other thing that also going
to change the way that you process the
tissue
is whether you want to work with all the
cells in the tissue or you want
you have just only a few a group of
cells that you that you are interested
you know you may only when interested in
cd45 positive cells or maybe
it's just only one b cell so t cells or
tumors
or ploy depending on the ploidy of the
cell so in this case you have to
introduce some sort of
fact sorting and and also that changes
the way that you process the tissue okay
now usually the way that you process the
tissue mechanically could be is the same
because you need to do single cells
for fact sorting but you know there is
another step that you introduce and that
is another step in which you may
introduce some
stress okay we will discuss later now
uh now one of the thing is
uh that i continue
the sort of insisting here is that there
are
protocols available for dissociation
from pretty much
every part of the body and i would
recommend to
before you just going blind and and just
use that that some x lab did
you do your pilot you take that protocol
protocols dot io
it has plenty of protocols available
there
and just talk get in touch with the with
the researchers talk to them
don't be afraid of talking to these
people
because they will actually give you the
tip some things cannot be written in
papers
okay and we all know that papers will
only have the things that are
successful but there are a lot of things
that are not successful
so discuss with them just get the time
in this zoom era era so make the time to
talk to them and
tell you to give you all these little
nitty gritty tips that are going to be
so important
for uh for the next stages
of your single cellerness which is
generating live single cell
suspension now of course the methodology
and the technology
that you're going to use whether using
droplet or plates
may have an impact in the way that you
will choose
to process your samples and that is it's
it's also very
uh important that you taking you take it
into account
now there are when you make the decision
uh
again this is not technically related to
sample processing
but it's something that i want to put
out there
up front when you make the decision of
what type of technology you're going to
use
make sure that you do an informed
decision just don't use the one that is
in fashion at the moment because
you know it's great and and and lab a
actually had a lot of success just
there are very beautiful benchmarking
studies again by the
by the um by the group of hoyle heng
and er and the eleven love here the
harvard and the broad institute in which
they have
spent thousands of thousands of dollars
doing comparisons across different
platforms
to give you not just the published
nature paper
but it's just to give you an idea of
what
is you know just making their making
easy for you just
these are the techniques these are the
ways that you
need to be looking and if you want gene
expression if you want
a you know cluster ability might be what
is that you're actually focusing here
just
make sure that you take these papers you
ring them and decide what technology is
more suitable to you okay i understand
that
some technologies are more common and
famous and
more easily handled easy to use which we
also discussed but
it's important that you do an informed
decision before you actually choose the
experiment because actually can save you
a lot of money
okay and headaches
and finally if you really want if you
want to do joint profiling for instance
if you want to do
a you know single-celled ataxic uh using
a nuclear attacks against single nuclear
arrest
you together uh uh or on
or simultaneously if you like you will
need you cannot prepare the nuclear in
the same way
okay you cannot prepare the cells in the
same way there will be some things that
are shared but then you need to separate
for example when you're using a nuclear
ataxic you need to permeabilize the
nucleus so if you permeabilize the
nuclei
you're going to lose rna okay some
people have shown that
in recent papers that they don't lose a
lot of rna
but there is a lot of loss of rna i i
have seen it at least
as i said this is my experience we've
seen lots of rna when we
when we permeabilize and then you'll end
up having
a you know you already have a lot
literal array in the nucleus so if you
keep permeabilizing you keep licking a
lot of rna you get a lot of background
especially if you're working
on a droplet based approach so
that would again so the whether you're
doing a job profiling or no it will
actually change the way that you prepare
your your single cell suspension
now the second part and and just
the second part of the process which is
the is the cell barcoding and and
non-sequencing so here again the same
situation the first thing that
happens is here is that when you
actually capture the cells
and and and you kind of individualize
the cell
and this is an important part because
once
once the cells is individualized that
happen in the in the previous case
there is something that it's very common
in all these applications you need to
essentially
individualize the transcript and you
need to make sure that
when you barcode you you you label that
paragraph we know informatically that
comes from z1 or c2 or c3
okay so in all these systems the cell
bar
coding happens pretty much in the same
way there are slightly differences
but the first thing that it happens is a
cell lysis so you light the cell and the
rna gets released
that whether that happens in a droplet
or it absolutely happens
in in in a world then all of them
use an illegal dt okay and and
and that oligo dt sometimes in the case
of for example of 10x
is in is in a dissolvable bead in the
case of
drop seek is on a solid beat and
and in some others also it's a solid bit
and in case of indro for example the
release
in the case of dropship there is no
release of the oligo in the case of
10x there is release of the oligo and it
gets off interrupt there is release of
the audio but the
release of the oligos is by a um via
um uv cleavage of the oligo and then
the oliver gets released and uh sort of
capture
the messenger rna through the poly a
again that can happen in droplet or in
well
and after that you get that first strand
synthesis that's a famous reverse
encryption step
right now in
some cases you get the rest
transcription in
uh in the droplet on the well like in
the case of 10x
in some cases you actually do the rest
transcription in mass
so for example in case your dropseek you
just it's only for a
tiny little period of time in which the
uh rna is it's uh in the droplet
so and the beads are in the droplet so
you capture the the rna with the quality
and then
you just break the droplets and the
non-transcribed rna
is just pulled together and then it's
transcribed in mass okay
just subtle differences which may or may
not have a high
impact in the quality of the data this
is not what we're discussing discussing
here but
you know different wife a way to do
sort of the same thing then you have
in in more in some in some instruments
you you know some technology you have
what is known as a template switching i
will discuss that in a little bit what
it is but it's essentially
it's a way of creating a dock inside for
a primer for cdna amplification
in in other approaches like in drops you
don't have a template switching okay so
what you do in
the case of interrupt is something
something different for sydney
amplification
and in the case of quad sig for example
you get an extension of a poly a
which er which sort of like changes
the way that um that you do the amp so
you create the
doc inside using activity not a
polyapolite
and then that is what is used as a dog
inside for a primer for cd amplification
now then you may or may not have a
second
synthesis that depends on the on the
method in the case of the next for
example you don't have a second
something
synthesis uh per se you you go straight
into the into the amplification
uh but in other in other technologies
you do and then
you do a cdna amplification in the case
of 10x
you have a pcr amplification that you
know we already know in the case of
probably if you're not very familiar
with the case of in-drop the standard in
drop
we we actually carry currently here at
the at the lab we have modified the
interrupt to actually
do what is called switch drop which
essentially is it's
basically the same approach that is used
10x
sort of a smart sake approach but it's
not the standard in drop
but in the standard interrupt what you
do have is once you have the cdna
as a as a hybrid what we do is
a segment strand we do sorry we do a rev
in vitro transcription and then from
that individual encryption
we um that's why we amplify the rna and
after that we do
uh reverse transcription again it's a
little bit cumbersome but it
actually the the the you know you can
generate single cell data
of high quality as well
and after that you know you that's
that's how you do the amplification and
from
from from from that you do you have to
fragment
the the material in the case of 10x you
can use
a enzymatic fermentation some others use
mechanical fermentation
in the case of in drop because you are
doing an in vitro transcription and then
you do a rest encryption
the fermentation happens not in no it's
not mechanic
it's not enzymatic it's happen because
you're using a random priming that binds
and
you know binds of different pieces and
different uh
places of the of the of the cdna and
after that
you make a you know the the most
important part for the
for for the next stage which is the
library preparation now another
preparation can be
a full length okay entire transcript
or you can be three prime or five prime
bias and the reason why you choose one
or the other depends on what you want to
do okay sometimes you want to
just only detect things that happen in
the three prime or just
all the five prime and you want to count
just molecule just
determine the number of molecules that
is between this
cell type and the other cell type and
between this transcript and the other
transcript but
you don't really want you don't you
don't care about potential rearranging
that may occur
in in the transcript for example fusion
genes or
or splice isoform so you just don't
don't worry about those okay and
the uh and in some other situations you
you do need and that's why you need to
do
a full length again not all of them
allow you to different lengths for
example 10x does you you can do full
length even though you have a full
length
uh cdna after the cdna amplification you
don't do that
for that you can do something like
smartsick for if you want to do full
length
but obviously a library that is a
full-length library is going to cost you
more
in the sequencing but it has huge amount
of advantages as well
and after that you know you go in the
sequencing step which you know is a very
important
part of everything now before
i'm gonna briefly mention what are the
different technology options that are
available
and then i will stop this this
part of the talk here and then i'm going
to resume
in about an hour uh so we can have a
little bit of
discussion here if you have any
questions i cover a lot of of parts here
so and
in the second part i will cover what a
little bit
a little bit of these technology options
but just as a
small teaser the the most
there are several technology options
that are available for using yourself
one of them is the one that you can do
in wells usually they are
sort of assisted by
either facts or you can also be assisted
by a
um liquid handler okay the most common
is assisted by
facts and then
you have cases like within this system
you have
cell sig mars six crop c quite sick
and then you have smart cigarettes i'm
going to mention a little bit more smart
sick because he's
is the one that has been sort of like
the grandfather of all these
uh other approaches and also because it
allows you to do something that not all
the other techniques allow you to do
then you have something like in
nanowells like in the case of segwell
and you can
also you have microwells and the case of
the rhapsody
and then you have the the the most
commonly used
at the moment are the things that are
done in droplets
uh in which we have chromium obviously
and we have in-drop
and we have a drop c so in
in the next second part of the talk i
will just briefly describe a little bit
of this
with a little bit more details comparing
these technologies and also getting to
some more uh juicy parts related to
also how to keep the preservation of
your tissue
and the dissociation of your tissue and
how to improve the preparation and some
some um things related to to
experimental design so if you
if you have any questions this is a good
time to
to us and then we can we can resume in
about an hour
thank you luciano for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q and a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions in the q a box
so our first question is
where do you see single cell and single
nuclei
rna-seq developing in the future
oh wow okay um look this
i will discuss a little bit briefly the
the the differences between these
these two and i think that these are you
know
they are not they don't they are not
mutually exclusive
what we do have is situations in which
we
may have what the samples that are
more amenable for a particular type of
of sequence of process
than others and i think one of the
things that i like
about single nuclear arrangement in
particular is that allows you to recover
those samples that sometimes
you cannot process uh using single cells
especially
those that have been frozen but i will i
will definitely discuss this
in the second part of of the talk
okay thank you our next question
what's the best way to preserve cell
viability
uh there is not a single way to do that
i think
the essentially you need to
know that your cells are the moment that
you dissociate them
they are not happy okay so you need to
keep them
oh try to keep them up four degrees as
much as you can but again you need to
know
what is the best uh media that you can
preserve them there is not a straight
answer for
everything so i think it dies depending
on
is it's very sample dependent and and
there is no one better than
yourselves to know what's the best
condition for your sample
and that is something that you probably
can
gather from from running some pilots on
on your samples
but there is not a recipe i know people
want
recipes this is the best way to do it
but in reality
this is not this is noah what happens
okay thank you luciano our next question
is
why is cell viability so important
uh well the survivability is important
because uh
in when you when the cells are dying
okay so imagine you have a suspension
when the cells are dying
a few things happen so the first thing
that the cells is going to do is just to
lose
this impermeability of the plasma
membrane and that
as that happens you start losing
rna out of the cells and when you lose a
rna of the cell that rna
if it is captured in a droplet for
example uh
so that rna is going to go into the
reverse transcription mix
okay and when you die it's capturing the
droplet you are introducing background
to the actual analysis okay now the
other thing that happens is that
because the rna comes out you
get and the and mitochondria cannot go
out
because this is a massive structure
compared to
to to the up uh to the holes that may be
created on the membrane
what you end up having is a lot of
mitochondria rates and that is actually
passing your your data so
it can be useful for some approaches but
usually these are not
this is not what you want okay another
thing that you will observe
is that all the rnas that are not able
to leave the cells are this
a long non-coding ronins that are
located in the nuclear they are usually
trapped in there
so what you end up having is a lot of
mitochondria rates
very low rna or feature counts
and and a lot of low
emi accounts and when you do have that's
that's what is diagnosed as a bad
quality cells and those cells are going
to be removed so you end up having
wasting a lot of date sequencing in
cells that eventually
or what we call barcodes that eventually
are going to be
removed because they are of bad quality
and of course
when you have that particular background
then
it's that is a badge effect that's what
on itself because then if you want to
introduce that if you want to compare
those cells with another
that this sample with another sample
that has been processed properly
that background is part of your you know
your analysis and that can actually also
introduce
uh you will have to correct for that
because that is introducing variability
in across the two data sets i i you know
aside of the fact that they are already
run
differently so all of that contributes
to
potentially making your data analysis
more difficult and
and and you buy information it's not
going to be happy with that
okay thank you got another question
when would you use facts or max
i will discuss that in the second part
of the talk
this is um you know this is an important
aspect but i will i would just go
through the slides in the second part so
if if
if you guys stayed i will i will
definitely describe one is better and
one is not okay
and uh replicates what's your opinion
again this is
something that comes in the second part
of the of the talk
okay um one last question here
um what is the most important factor for
successful
single cell sequencing outcomes
uh well they are not really a
unique single seller
unique aspect i think probably cell
viability is the thing that i would try
to preserve in every single time and try
not to stress the
the tissue much but again this is
there is not a particular thing that's
why they still have so many different
parts because every single part actually
contributes
to a high quality
data sets
well thank you so much luciano we're out
of time for today
um but don't worry audience any
questions that are submitted and not
answered today
by our speaker will be addressed via
email
thank you again luciano and thank you to
the audience for those outstanding
questions
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months
please remember to share it with the
with colleagues who might be interested
in today's topic
and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
goodbye